police telling us las vegas raiders
running back josh jacobs was arrested
earlier today in a suspected dui crash
officers say the single vehicle
collision happened near the airport
connector in sunset
earlier this morning raiders head coach
john gruden addressing the media at his
weekly press conference and he did speak
about the incident
sports director chris matthews joining
us with more on the incident chris
well thank you kirsten yeah the the one
car crash near the airport happened
about 12 hours after the raiders beat
the broncos in denver
josh jacobs scoring two touchdowns in
that game
and then at some point following the
flight home from denver he was involved
in that crash
authorities say that resulted from being
impaired metro released in a statement
today
detailing what happened that led to his
arrest jacobs was banged up a little bit
taken to the hospital and then
transported to clark county detention
center
where he was booked for dui we're just
aware of it
i will say that josh is okay
and i'm not at liberty to comment on it
until i get more facts but we do have
word that josh is okay and
we are looking into the matter all right
now following the arrest jacob's
attorney david chesnov released in a
statement saying no complaint has been
filed against our client and there are
no blood test results to support a
suggestion of impairment
we intend to enter a not guilty plea on
behalf of mr jacobs
if he is charged the arrest certainly
put a different spin on gruden's weekly
monday press conference but
he did talk about the changes that need
to be made to improve the team
that's coming up on channel eight at six
o'clock